le fond de la campagne vaccinale aux
états unis de texas fait bande à part
une fois de plus le gouverneur
républicain interdit l'obligation
vaccinale des entités de son état y
compris aux entreprises privées n'ont
pas tout de suite avec notre
correspondante aux abonnés à washington
bonsoir thomas c'est une décision qui va
à contre-courant des des choix du
président biden d'une façon certainement
pour le texas une fois encore de mener
sa fronde anti démocrate
oui parce qu'en réalité cela fait des
semaines que ce gouverneur républicain
du texas s'oppose à la maison blanche
sera un grand nombre de sujets et
particulièrement sur cette crise
sanitaire cette fois donc le gouverneur
républicain du texas greg abbott a
décidé d'interdire la mise en place des
obligations de vaccination pour toutes
les entités à texane et dans le décret
qui a été signé ce lundi on comprend que
c'est une réaction directe aux mesures
présidentielles prises par joe baydan
écouter
considérons que dans une nouvelle et
exagérations des instances fédérales
l'administration byden malmène
maintenant beaucoup d'entités privées
pour imposer des obligations de
vaccination causant des interruptions de
travail qui menace le rétablissement du
texas suite au désastre du coc vide 19
aucune entité au texas ne peut
contraindre à la présentation d'une
preuve de vaccination contre le coc u19
incluant les employés et les clients qui
s'opposent à une telle vaccination pour
quelconque raison de conscience
personnelle basée sur une croyance
religieuse ou pour des raisons médicales
comme une ancienne guérison ducobu 19
alors pour compléter ses propos et
montrer qu'il n'était pas anti vaccin
agrégat bot a tweeté le vaccin covic 19
est sûre efficace et constitue notre
meilleure défense contre le virus mais
il doit toujours rester volontaire et
jamais forcé alors les contrevenants
dans l'état du texas risqueront une
amende allant jusqu'à 1000 $ et ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que l'état du texas
comme l'état de floride d'ailleurs sont
donc deux états qui sont gouvernés par
des républicains et cela fait maintenant
plusieurs mois qu'ils se sont constitués
en figure de résistance en quelque sorte
aux mesures prises échelle fédéral
d'ailleurs il ya eu une réaction il y à
quelques instants à peine de la part de
la porte parole de la maison blanche
james acquis qui dit regretter que ces
deux gouverneurs place la politique au
dessus de la santé publique et aux bras
c'est dans ce contexte qu'une compagnie
aérienne a connu des perturbations ces
derniers jours peut-on y voir un lien
avec la mise en place de la vaccination
obligatoire pour les employés justement
et bien c'est tout le débat stéphanie
faut d'abord savoir que ce dimanche plus
de mille vols ont été annulés par cette
compagnie aérienne southwest airlines
alors dans un premier temps l'entreprise
s'est justifié en prétextant des
problèmes de météo ainsi que des
problèmes de contrôle aérien mais pour
certains notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux on a pu lire des tweets par
exemple du sénateur républicain à tête
cruz est bien pour eux elle ces
problèmes étaient une conséquence
directe de la mise en place de
l'obligation de vaccination pour les
employés de cette entreprise ce qui
aurait donc entraîner des absences mais
c'est une thèse qui a été réfutée
d'abord par un syndicat de pilotes de
l'air puis par le patron de l'entreprise
southwest airlines lui même qui a donné
une interview en expliquant qu'il
s'agissait en réalité de problèmes
d'effectifs et des problèmes de planning
mais son interview n'a pas suffi à
éteindre toutes ces rumeurs qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que dans la même interview le patron de
south west explique aussi qu'il est
farouchement opposé à l'obligation de
vaccination mais qu'il est contraint de
s'y plier pour respecter les mesures
prises par joe biden qui je vous le
rappelle a imposé la vaccination à plus
de 100 millions de salariés sur
l'ensemble du territoire d'ici le 8
décembre prochain il ya un fait qui est
intéressant c'est que cette compagnie
aérienne southwest airlines a son siège
dans l'état du texas ce qui veut dire
qu'elle pourrait ne plus se contraindre
à ces directions directives prises
niveau fédéral et justement se soumettre
à ces nouvelles mesures prises par le
gouverneur républicain mais finalement
on a appris que cette entreprise allait
bel et bien se plier à ses obligations
de vaccination mais il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont en réalité dans
le même cas de figure qui ont leur siège
basé au texas et on devrait donc avoir
des batailles juridiques dans les
semaines à venir avec évidemment font
une opposition entre les républicains de
ces états et l'administration démocrate
et puis une dernière information pour
finir stéphanie je sais que vous aimez
bien le basket et bien sachez qu'un
joueur de l'équipe de brooklyn vient
d'être écarté par son équipe parce que
lui aussi refusent de se faire vacciner
alors dans leur championnat de basket
aux états unis il n'y a pas d'obligation
de vaccination mais le fait qu'il évolue
dans une équipe qui est basée à new york
et bien cela à l'empêchent de pouvoir
jouer les matches à domicile de son
équipe raison pour laquelle il a été
écarté et preuve que l'obligation de
vaccination mis en place aux états unis
a des répercussions sur tout un tas de
secteurs effectivement merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington